gut dann begrüßte sie zur heutigen
sitzung in der wir uns mit einem ganz
bekannten philosophen befassen werden
nämlich mit diesen netten herrn hier
und weil sie wird von dem titel heißt
das ist natürlich aristoteles carpaccio
immanuel kant und er hat ein ganz
wichtiges werk geschrieben und nämlich
die kritik der reinen 5 und aus diesem
hauptwerk von immanuel kant werden wir
heute ein ganz zentralen ausschnitt
gemeinsam lesen und diskutieren und zwar
geht es jetzt um die sogenannte dritte
antinori der vernunft die dritte am knie
die tritte antinori was das jetzt genau
ist werden wir noch sehen was eine
antinori ist und es geht dann auch um
andere fragen die wir heute behandeln
werden nämlich zum beispiel diese frage
hier wie gelingt es kant freiheits und
natur kausalität zusammen zu denken das
ist eine spannende frage
und eine andere spannende frage ist nur
ob ganz position er kompatibel ist ist
oder ihr liberta realistisch das ist
auch noch nicht ganz spannende frage
weil es nicht klar ist welche position
riskant hier angesichts der
gegenwärtigen theorien eigentlich
bezieht also es ist eine riesen debatte
wie man kann's position klassifizieren
soll ist also gar nicht so klar und das
wollen wir eben jetzt in der heutigen
sitzung versuchen hier mal uns ein
bisschen klarheit darüber zu verschaffen
in welcher position welche position
kennt hier übernimmt ich kann schon so
viel verraten es ist wahrscheinlich
weder das eine noch das andere
es gibt eine gewisse nähe zu einer
position aber ob es jetzt kompatibel is
muss oder liberta realismus ist für
beide optionen gibt es sehr gute
argumente und das wollen wir heute in
der sitzung klären
wir wollen auch noch schauen ob kann in
seiner dritten antinori noch andere
positionen hier erwähnt die für uns auch
noch von interesse sein könnten
jetzt müssen wir noch mal ganz kurz
klären was eine antinori ist also eine
anti nomi da steht natürlich anti anti
heißt auf deutsch gegen und noomi da
steckt das griechische wort mamas drin
und normalos heißt einfach gesetzt und
es als 1 gegen gesetz also ein gegensatz
so das sagt ja ein widerstreit kann es
spricht auch manchmal ein widerstreit
entgegen satz zwei sätze oder gesetze
vielleicht noch das allerbeste zwei
gesetzte wieder streiten sich da hat man
es eigentlich sehr gut hier weil kann
wird jetzt davon sprechen dass wir es
einerseits mit dem naturgesetz zu tun
haben und wir haben es mit dem freiheits
gesetz zu tun
das freiheits gesetz ist das gesetz der
vernunft und das ist das gesetz des
kategorischen imperativ ist ein gesetz
was uns nicht die natur vorschreibt weil
die natur sagt kann an einer stelle in
dieser kritik der reinen vernunft gesagt
uns nur was ist aber nicht was sein soll
die natur hat vielleicht wenn man solche
tage genauer betrachtet so eine schwache
form von normativität erhält man diese
sollen eine normativität natur macht uns
vielleicht in ganz geringen sinne schon
vorschriften zum beispiel gibt es
lebensweisen wenn man sich ungesund
ernährt dass dann der körper krank wird
dann kann man daraus schliessen wir
sollen nichts zu essen
aber wer sagt denn dass der körper
erhalten werden sollen wer sagt denn
dass kann man sagen gute
evolutionstheorie sagt uns die evolution
will die natur will dass wir uns immer
weiterentwickeln
aber ist das wirklich so so steht's denn
und das ist doch auch nur so ein schluss
den wir da ziehen oder etwas das wir in
die natur hineinlegen also mit dieser
normativität mit dem sollen und der
natur
ist es nicht so gut bestellt wird kann
auch sagen kann wird sagen die natur ist
etwas was nur mit dem sein zu tun hat
nichts mit dem sollen zu tun hat also
werte und moral
solche erwägungen kommen in der natur
nicht vor
das heißt das naturgesetz sagt nur was
ist und sein wird wenn wir die
ausgangsbedingungen haben das
naturgesetz haben oder alle naturgesetze
haben kann später nur von einem
naturgesetz
wir sprechen heutzutage von
verschiedenen naturgesetzen kräften die
wirken anziehungskräften da gibt es ja
vier kräfte starke schwache
elektromagnetische und so weiter und so
fort und gravitationskraft ist noch eine
vierte kraft kann spricht nur von einem
gesetz es kommt aufs selbe hinaus weil
wir mit dem gesetz alle zukünftigen
ereignisse berechnen können wenn wir
einen ausgangszustand haben dass sie
sehen das führt dann in die position des
determinismus das determinismus dass wir
eben alles vorhersagen können dass nicht
nur alles vorhersagbar ist sondern noch
stärker alles vorherbestimmt ist das ist
die pre termination das naturgesetz und
jetzt zeit kannte es gibt auch noch ein
anderes gesetz oder zumindest können uns
ein anderes gesetz denken neben dem
naturgesetz
und zwar ist das dass vernunft gesetz
oder das freiheits gesetz das ist jetzt
mal das ist jetzt mal ungefähr dasselbe
ja es gibt also gesetzlichkeit die aus
der natur stand und gesetzlichkeit die
aus der vernunft stammt oder die mit
unserer freiheit zu tun hat wir können
sogar auch noch auf diese seite hier
schreiben dass moral gesetzt
das ist also alles mehr oder weniger
dasselbe vernunft gesetz freiheits
gesetz moral gesetzt und hier ist das
sagen das sind jetzt die zwei gesetze
die sich jetzt hier wieder streiten und
hier haben wir das sein und wir haben
wir das sonnen dass moral gesetz sagt
uns natürlich was wir tun sollen
der kategorische imperativ sagt wie wir
handeln sollen wir sollen so handelt
dass unsere maximen das heißt unsere
subjektiven handlungs grundsätze sich
als ein allgemeines gesetz und da haben
wir wieder das gesetz als ein
allgemeines gesetz verstehen lassen
also wir kommen nicht umhin umgesetzt
angesetzten kommen wir nicht vorbei das
ist kann es einzig aber wir haben so
scheint es jedenfalls wenn wir uns die
welt anschauen wie sie läuft wir haben
zwei gesetze und die gesetze stehen sich
gegenüber weil sein und sollen eben
nicht unbedingt aufeinander reduzierbar
sind das ist eine ganz große frage in
der philosophie
ich habe im letzten jahr eine tagung
dazu gemacht sie finden auch die einige
der vorträge rechtsbogen jetzt in der
aufzeichnung auf die lowcost da mache
ich den link rhein wo wir diese frage
geklärt haben oder versucht haben zu
erklären wie verhalten sich denn jetzt
sein und sollen zueinander also kann das
sollen auf das seien reduziert werden
also sagen kann wer in der natur in dem
was ist was naturgesetzlich betreiber
ist in dem was faktisch vorliegt
können wir darin spuren von normativität
vom sollen finden
jetzt frage ich sie wer glaubt dass das
möglich ist mehr glaubt dass das nicht
möglich ist wer glaubt dass es möglich
ist dass wir das sollen auf das sein
reduzieren können wer glaubt dass wir in
der natur normativität vorfinden können
mutig nur zu ja okay gut zwei personen
oder eine halbe halbe meldung oder ganze
ja ok haben sie argumente dafür oder
eine intuition
im video
in vielen schritten
genau das ist ein klassischer punkt der
auf die antike lehre zurück geht zum
beispiel aristoteles platon ist die
frage ob twitter
ich glaube davon haben noch eine größere
unterscheidung zwischen sein und sollen
wobei wenn sie mal genau hinschauen bei
platin ist es so ich will jetzt nicht zu
sehr ein exkurs machen weil plattform
ist es so wie sie wissen die idee des
guten
die ist ganz stark normativ und idee des
guten die steht aber irgendwie noch über
allem sein aber sie ist irgendwie auch
was sein dass also bei platin kommt dass
nämlich ein bisschen mehr zusammen bei
aristoteles und darauf haben sie sich
jetzt wahrscheinlich bezog oder auch die
mittelalterliche leere da ist es ebenso
technologie heißt wir sind durch unsere
natur so verfasst dass wir auf etwas
bestimmtes ausgerichtet sind wir streben
nach glückseligkeit nach vollendung und
diese streben zeigt uns werte an die
natürlich begründet wir streben von
natur aus nach natürlichen werten also
nach vielleicht gesundheit oder auch
moralischer vervollkommnung oder
tugendhaftigkeit das ist aber in unserem
natürlichen leben angelegt deswegen gibt
es eine moderne philosophie heißt
philippe a foot ich glaube mit zwei
schreibt man sich sicher ich glaube nur
mit einem und die hat einen begriff ein
werk geschrieben das heißt dass handelt
von der natural gas natural guten ist
das natürlich gute die deutsche
übersetzung von diesen werken erfolgen
das heißt die natur des guten aber das
natürlich keine gute übersetzung weil es
geht nicht um die natur des guten sein
es geht um die die natürliche
sagen also es geht um das gute als natur
und nicht weil die natur lässt sich
jemals im doppelten sinne verstehen
natur kann auch im sinne des wesens
verstanden werden also natürlich total
müsste man das eigentlich übersetzt als
natürliche gut wer so was sagt eine
solche theorie der natürlichen gut
vertritt der wird natürlich tendenziell
zu haben ja wir können das gute das
sollen die ganzen nördlichen prädikate
im sein der natur finden aufzeigen
also es gibt noch einige philosophen die
das heutzutage tun aber es ist ein
bisschen etwas aus der mode gekommen
auf der anderen seite gibt es solche neo
aristotelischen ansätze die
aristotelische mein theorien die
versuchen mit aristoteles in der
gegenwärtigen debatte wieder
mitzuspielen und die behaupten eben auch
dass wir von unserer natur aus dazu
angelegt sind auf das gute aus zu sein
ich habe damit große problem mit diesem
ansatz ist mein persönlicher sicht weil
wie sieht es dann mit dem lösung aus ist
das böse da nur so ein defekt wie so
eine krankheit dass uns einfach so
passiert ich glaube ich nicht glaube wir
tun das unmoralische auch ganz bewusst
manchmal oder aus freiheit jedenfalls
und dann bekommen wir mit diesem bild
ein bisschen probleme aber das ist jetzt
ein riesen anderes thema wenn sie in
sich dafür interessieren können sie auch
auf meinem ich hatte mal so ein wiki
seminar gemacht von paar jahren das ging
nur um das thema sein und soll diesen
link werde ich auch in die youtube
beschreibung und mein tun da sie da mal
drauf klicken können können sich durch
sein ganzes wird über sagen sollen mal
durchklicken
genau das jetzt nur so als eine kurze
vorwegnahme dieser problematik
jetzt wollen wir mal mitten in dem text
hinein gehen das ist jetzt der text aus
der original ausgabe der jetzt von der
rechtschreibung nicht mehr man nicht
mehr unserer heutigen ganz entspricht
die gibt es zum beispiel
insgesamt wird jetzt mit zwei ihm
geschrieben das ist halt aus der
originalausgabe und kausalität wird mit
c geschrieben stand k
also jetzt gibt es hier diese angenommen
die antenne wird aufgespannt durch eine
these days und eine antike es ist eine
gegenthese entgegen satz anti bedeutet
eben wie wir schon gesagt haben dagegen
und kann zeigt jetzt es gibt in unserer
vernunft deswegen ist die dritte an dem
ihn der vernunft in unserer vernunft in
unserem rationalität haben wir zwei
grund sagt jetzt nicht grund intuitionen
aber grundüberzeugungen die eigentlich
ziemlich vernünftig gerechtfertigt sind
und unsere fans gibt uns zwei thesen vor
das eine und das andere und beide thesen
sind auf den ersten blick eigentlich
völlig unscheinbar
das heißt unsere vernunft kommt mit sich
in einen widerstreit das ist etwas
paradox so sollte unsere vernunft mit
sich selbst widersprechen
ganz hat so ist es jedenfalls die
vernunft die widerspricht sich weil sie
zwei unterschiedliche ansichten vertritt
bezogen auf die freiheit und sie können
sich schon denken was die
unterschiedlichen ansichten sind
das ist diese eine these dass wir eben
total determiniert sind dass es keine
freiheit gibt und die andere these ist
und das ist jetzt die these hier jetzt
geht das wir eben durchaus frei sind
weil wir nicht nur durch das chaos
eingesetzte terminiert sind
und er setzt sich lesen bevor die
kausalität nach gesetzen der natur also
naturgesetz ist nicht dass die einzige
welche die erscheinungen der welt
insgesamt abgeleitet werden können es
ist noch eine kausalität durch freiheit
zur erklärung derselben anzunehmen
notwendig wie geht's jetzt sogar noch
genauer gesagt und kausalität es geht
jetzt gar nicht so sehr um gesetze
es geht um kausalitäten also es geht um
wirkende gesetze könnte man sagen ja wie
könnte man jetzt diese position nennen
wie könnte man die jetzt mit unseren
positionen die wir jetzt kennengelernt
habe
ja
[Musik]
diese causa durch freiheit ist die frage
wie man sie nennen sollte es geht
sicherlich in die richtung der logik
aber wenn sie jetzt mal diese position
der these mit einer aktuellen files
theoretischen position mit zeichen
sollten wir hier würden sie dann ihr
vorschlag ist nicht ganz klar
kompatibel ist muss wäre eine
möglichkeit
wir haben also zwei gesetzlichkeiten und
beide koexistieren was gibt es nur für
die möglichkeit liberta realismus wäre
auch noch so ein bisschen die
möglichkeit wenn man sagen würde die
kausalität nach gesetzen der natur
die reicht nicht aus die ist zu schwach
wir brauchen noch eine andere eine
kausalität um die geht es also entweder
detail also kompatibel ismus oder
libertarian ist muss wahrscheinlich eher
ein bisschen mehr kompatibel ist muss
hier aber liberta realismus wäre auch
vielleicht denkt die der militarismus
müsste eben sagen denn determinismus ist
falsch und dann müsste man sagen gibt
die kausalität nach gesetzen der natur
ist nicht die einzige das müsste man
sodann re formulieren sie ist eben der
determinismus ist nicht so zu verstehen
dass alles irgendwie bestimmt dass ich
selbst mal schauen und jetzt wird diese
these ist noch ein bisschen weiter
ausgeführte zeigt es gibt ein beweis
dafür
man nehme an es gebe keine kausalität
als nach gesetzen der natur also keine
freiheit kausalität so setzt alles was
geschieht ein vorigen zustand voraus auf
den es nun aus bleibt nach einer regel
voll die regel ist das gesetz man muss
aber der vorige zustand selbst etwas
sein was geschehen ist in der zeit
geworden da es vorher nicht
weil wenn es jeder zeit gewesen wäre
seine folge auch nicht alle erst
entstanden sondern immer gewesen sein
hörte als er ist die kausalität der
ursache durch etwas geschieht selbst
etwas geschehen ist welches nach dem
gesetze der natur wiederum allen vorigen
zustand und dessen qualität dieser aber
ebenso einen noch älteren voraussetzt
und so weiter wenn also alles nach losen
gesetze natur geschieht so gibt es
jederzeit nur einen subalternen niemals
aber einen ersten anfang also überhaupt
keine vollständigkeit der auf der seite
der voneinander abstammenden ursachen
nun besteht aber eben darin das gesetz
der natur das ohnehin reicht apriori
bestimmte ursachen nichts geschehen also
widerspricht der satz als wenn alle
kausalität nur nach naturgesetzen
möglich sei sich selbst in seiner
uneingeschränkten allgemeinheit und
diese kann also nicht als die einzige
angenommen werden wo jedes aber ein
ziemlich lange beweis und jetzt frage
ich sie wie läuft denn jetzt dieser
beweis ab was ist das für eine methode
die er hier wählt wie kann man diesen
beweis nennen
[Musik]
es geht so ein bisschen diese richtung
nennt man diese also dass man nehme an
es gebe keine andere kausalität
also man nimmt jetzt erst mal dass
entgegen gesetzt genau einen widerspruch
soll weiß wie nennt man dennoch gibt es
ein lateinisches oder wenn sie mal
schauen das hat uns haben sie in der
logik haben sie das gemacht der logik
dass das gegenteil annehmen es ist
absurd ab
eine reduktion absurd um also nimmt das
gegenteil an und folgt folgert aus dem
gegenteil die falschheit und da ist nur
entweder das eine oder das andere sein
kann folgt daraus dass eben die
ursprüngliche these vielen direkt
erwiesen ist ins eben nur die zwei
möglichkeiten gibt ja ich versuche jetzt
einfach mal so wir haben hier eben oder
b obwohl jetzt dass hier nicht das
ausschließen ist fassen wir das einmal
ausschließen aufhören das ja und oder
fassen wir nochmal ausschließt auf und
wir haben hier gezeigt dass es falsch
ist und daraus folgt dann das ist das
ist sozusagen der die reduktion absolut
uns ein bisschen es gibt entweder sei
jetzt hier
wir brauchen noch die freiheits
kausalität zusätzlich zur natur
konsultiert und gesagt wir brauchen nur
die natur kausalität das kann man sich
natürlich fragen stehen a und wie
wirklich ein kontradiktorischen
gegensatz folgt also aus nun pa oder aus
9b ist schon mal die frage aber wenn wir
das als solches setzen und dann die
falschheit von b zeigen können weil es
eben wie sie sagen es so ins und regress
führt und eric es wäre eben die
falschheit wir kommen nie zum ersten
anfang dann würde daraus eben indirekt
folgen
aber wir haben nicht direkt bewiesen
sondern aus der fall stefan b eine
reduktion absurd um
das setzt voraus wie gesagt das a und b
sich kontradiktorisch entgegenstehen
das also sie aus der negation heraus
ergeben und es ist auch nicht so klar
hier ob das so der fall ist das müsste
man ein bisschen genauer noch klären wir
wollen das können sie aber dann
hausarbeit tun werden sie sich dafür
interessieren wir wollen heute einfach
mal den gedankengang nachvollziehen wir
sind das argument klar warum eben b
falsch ist
sie würden sagen der der regress ist
kein hinweis auf die falschheit er sagt
also hier das ohne hinreichend
abgestimmt ursache nichts geschehen
das wäre das gesetz der natur
wie sehen sie das ist das problematisch
stimmt das was könnt ihr sagt
ich denke auch weil er geht jetzt immer
eigentlich von den ursachen außen sagt
gut die ursache jede ursache hat
wiederum eine ursache ist die wirkung
des wald sich zueinander
also sowieso kettenglieder die sich
überlappen bis ins unendliche kette geht
in beide richtung müssen endlich aber
folgt daraus dass es keine ursache gibt
stehen sie dazu
wenn es bis in alle unendlichkeit
zurückgeht widerspricht es ein
naturgesetz ja eigentlich nicht geld das
naturgesetz sagte einfach nur dass es so
abläuft das naturgesetz sagt einfach nur
es muss so ablaufen
das problem ist kann denkt so ein
bisschen den randbereich denkt also die
ersten anfall
es muss doch einmal ein erster anfang
gegeben haben sonst könnte doch gar
nichts wirklich ursache sein
das geht irgendwie unendlichkeit
sie kennen sie vielleicht auch ein
bisschen um endlich keiten auf aktuelle
unendlichkeit und solche solche sachen
also hier müsste man sie jetzt genau mit
der unendlichkeit struktur dieses
gesetzes befassen aber gegen ein gesetz
spricht es jedenfalls nicht das ist ja
gerade ausdruck das gesetz ist ja aber
das problem ist halt wie kommt dieses
gesetz überhaupt zustande
also dann gerät dieses gesetz dann kommt
dieses gesetz dadurch dazu wirksam zu
werden
das setzt natürlich voraus dass ist
irgendwann mal so einen ersten anstoß
gab ihr könnt das gesetz setzen
aber es muss ja irgendwann mal
angewendet werden das gesetz losgelassen
werden ich glaube dass er darauf sind
bislang spielt die die wirkungs die lobt
dass das in gang gesetzt
gang gesetzt werden des gesetzes die
einsetzung des gesetzes also wenn sie
darüber nach hausarbeit schreiben wollen
war es ein sehr gutes thema ist dann
können sie gerne sich damit mal genauer
beschäftigen
diese frage als er will jetzt hier also
beweisen dass wir neben der natur
kausalität noch eine kausalität brauchen
nämlich die freiheits kausalität diesem
nach muss als aus der falschheit von b
muss eine kausalität angenommen werden
durch will ich etwas geschieht ohne dass
die ursache davon noch weiter durch eine
andere vorhergehende ursache nach
notwendigen gesetze bestimmt sein
das heißt eine absolute spontaneität der
ursachen eine reihe von erscheinungen
die nach naturgesetzen verläuft läuft
von selbst anzufangen
mithin transzendentale freiheit ohne
welche selbst im laufe der natur die
reihenfolge der erscheinungen auf der
seite der ursachen niemals vollständig
ist okay was at
unser projekt ist und den ganzen tag
genau
also wir müssen uns das jetzt so denken
wir haben hierbei wenn wir das
naturgesetz als solches betrachten
keinen ersten anfang
wir werden immer weiter zurück gereicht
bis ins unendliche
und hier ist es jetzt so damit wir
überhaupt diesen startpunkt bekommen mit
dem das naturgesetz in gang gesetzt wird
kann brauchen wir sagt kant eine andere
form von kommerzialität nämlich eine wie
er hier sagt eine absolute spontaneität
implizieren
das heißt ein absolutes spontanität was
ist denn ein absolutes kontinent gehen
sie mal ein beispiel
das bedeutet spontaneität
mainz wird man sehen sie denn spontan
geben sie mal ein beispiel von
spontanität im alltag
wie würden sie die spontanität im alltag
formulieren grübeln sieht er lange oder
was passiert bei einer spontanen
handlungen ja genau das war mit ihrem
auch schon mit der willkür
es hat damit etwas zu tun als es erstmal
solle ja fast aus dem nichts kommende
entscheidungen macht es jetzt einfach
sitze ohne großen anlauf mache ich das
nennen spontan vom lateinischen heißt
einfach nur aus eigenem antrieb konnte
heißt aus eigenem antrieb von selbst
vielleicht ist das das griechische dies
vielleicht automaten also auch selbst
bewegt eigenem antrieb und jetzt haben
natürlich das problem der willkür wenn
das einfach so geschieht es ist dann
nicht einfach beliebig man könnte aber
sagen gutes folgt ja aus der vernunft
spontan als es nicht beliebig es ist ja
gerade hier unser
unser von unserer vernunft die uns das
gebietet und die den ersten grund der
handlung bietet
denn hätte etwas mit der spontaneität
gemeinsam als es einfach so plötzlich
auftritt aber im ergänzt so dass das
dann selbst das phänomen selbst nicht
mehr
wenn ich es recht verstehe dieser
gesetzlichkeit unterliegt als wir haben
bei ergänzt und kausalität immer ein
problem weil das elegante phänomen
eigentlich kausal nicht wirksam ist ja
das ist eigentlich so nebenprodukt also
wir haben wir müssen die ihm agenten
phänomene immer beschreiben durch die
kausalen kräfte qualitäten die ihm
zugrunde liegen aus denen es im agiert
also dass immer gelte phänomen wie zum
beispiel jetzt bewusst sein sagen viele
wenn besonders viele neuronen
zusammenkommen da wohne und zirpt dicht
gepackt sind in unserem gehirn dann
tritt irgendwann ganz plötzlich unser
bewusstsein auf das ist ein effekt der
dichte oder komplexität unseres
netzwerkes und bei opel das problem ist
bei im ergänzt dass man dann die mentale
qualität unseres denkens nicht mehr
unabhängig von dem naturgesetzlich
verfassten regeln unseres gehirns
erklären kann
also wir haben ein problem der erklärung
von mentaler verursachung als sie haben
insofern recht dass das hier zum ergänzt
hat dass es so etwas plötzlich es ist
aber bezogen auf die kausalität und ich
sagen ist es anders weil ergänzt
phänomene sich nicht mehr durch eine
neue form von kausalität bestimmen
lassen sondern die müssen reduziert
werden
auf die basis aus den zehn agieren
ja genau
ganz genau genau es wäre vielleicht
etwas was nicht so in der zeit liegt was
nicht in diesem zeitlichen dank der
determination blick etwas was halt wie
so eine art absoluter beweger ist sie
kennen dessen eine absolute ursache
ursache seiner selbst zu sein zu lassen
das etwas eben plötzlich ohne vorläufer
zu haben einfach geschehen und dann hier
die kausalketten in gang gesetzt ohne
dass und hier ist nichts da ist nichts
davon
plötzlich kommt das ist die absolute
spontanität der usa
qualität
ja also willkür gibt's ja habe ich ja im
aufsatz darüber geschrieben
den kann ich auch in youtube link unten
rein machen will quer ist ja ein sehr
schwieriges wort erstmal man ist ja was
macht der heutigen aus der heutigen
sicht bedeutet große beliebigkeit als
will kühlen nach dem heutigen
verständnis schließt jede form von
gesetzlichkeit eigentlich ausmacht es
einfach willkürlich und es war jetzt
ihre frage ja bekannt würde hier sagen
nach dem schlechten begriff von wir
können nach der bloßen liebig kann wäre
diese folgen von kausalität nicht
willkürlich weil sie eben nachdem hier
gerade aus dem freiheits gesetz kommt
also das wäre jetzt eben durchaus etwas
gesetzliches und nicht beliebig sondern
kann fast etwas notwendiges diese form
der der kausalität willkürlichkeit hat
ja in der regel nichts mit qualität zu
tun nichts mit gründen und so zu tun
nach dem schlechten begriff ja ich
glaube nicht dass wir willkür so
verstehen sollten aber es gibt eben
diese alltägliche bedeutung gefunden
und hier sagt er diese absolute ursache
die ist a priori vor alle erfahrungen
durch normativität durch diese ganze
sich hier durch vernunft durch
normativität usw geprägte auf das ganze
hinauslaufen
deswegen würde sagt nach dem eigenen ein
allgemein gängigen begriff der würde ich
dann nach kann jetzt nicht als
willkürlich bezeichnet
wir müssen uns dann überlegen was es
dann ist jedenfalls ein erster anfang
der überhaupt sowas wie das in gang
setzen das in gang kommen der kausalität
möglich macht dies ein als wenn wir
praktisch zum absoluten anfang haben
dann kann die kausalkette auch die natur
in gang gesetzt werden wenn wir aus den
freiheits ab irgendwann fingen sie an so
ein urknall wersen urknall knallt ist
zum beispiel der erste punkt das ist als
auch eine kosmologische frage nach die
nach dem allerersten anfang und zur welt
der urknall
er kommt plötzlich war es und dann geht
alles los dann beginnen die kausalen
gesetze kausalketten durchzulaufen und
die naturgesetze sich auszuwirken
davor war nichts ja und jetzt kann man
sich also überlegen dass freiheit so was
wie sein kleiner urknall sein muss in
uns ja das ist so die idee dahinter
aber
[Musik]
draußen
mit
genauer er denkt jetzt vollständigkeit
wenn ich ein recht versteht ihr bezogen
auf den anfang
also würde sagen wir können hier gar
nicht von einer wirklichen
ursächlichkeit sprechen wenn es nicht
irgendwann mal begonnen hat
wohltätigkeit setzt was wie beginn
voraus das problem scheint mir die linke
seite zu sein als die rechte natürlich
wenn beide enden offen sind haben wir
das problem
er sagt also vollständig ist eine
kausalkette nur dann wenn das erste
glied der kette eine ursache ist dann
kommt wirkung
das kann ein bisschen unendliche gehen
aber er betrachtet sie den anfangspunkt
man solange wir kein ersten anfang haben
sagt kant ist die kette einfach
unvollständig sie könnte dann aber
prinzipiell bis ins unendliche
in der zeit nach rechts laufen wenn wir
von links einen ersten anfang haben so
lese ich jetzt kann also die
unendlichkeit nach rechts ist kein
ablehnen würde ich sagen nur die
unendlichkeit nach links wäre es ein
bisschen probleme in der zeit oder wir
sehen sie ist also vollständigkeit ab
jetzt glaube ich nicht so gedacht werden
das ist ja der punkt dass irgendwann mal
hier ende ist hier am ende und dann die
vollständig ist und vollständigkeit muss
glaube ich so gedacht werden dass wir
die ganze kirche überhaupt in gang
setzen können dass wir mal so einen
ursächlichen anfang haben das meint der
glaube ja
[Musik]
ja schauen wir doch noch mal zurück hier
kurz also hier
wenn also alles nach losen gesetzen
natur geschieht so gibt es jederzeit nur
einen spalt ernen niemals aber einen
ersten anfang und also überhaupt keine
vollständigkeit in der reihe auf der
seite wir voneinander abstammen ursachen
das ist wohl nach links bezogen glaube
ich oder also subalternen meint ja immer
also ja er wird es sagen wir haben eben
immer nur relative kausalitäten ja wir
haben immer nur relative das wäre zwar
eine ursache dann hier das linke das
glied ganz links links der kette das
wäre zwar eine ursache aber bezogen auf
die vorhergehende ursache ohne wirkung
und wenn sie das so weiter denken dann
haben sie eigentlich immer nur wirkungen
zu sagen sie also dasselbe phänomen ist
zugleich eine ursache wie eine wirkung
bis ins unendliche zurück sie kommen nie
zu einem wirklichen ursache dass das
problem jedes ereignis kann da es immer
wieder vorhergehende ereignisse gibt
hier es verursacht sowohl als wirkung
wie auch als ursache gesehen wird wir
brauchen aber etwas was eindeutig als
ursache zu klassifizieren ist und dann
alles in gang setzen zu können
das ist glaube ich das was in meinen
also wenn wir das bis endlich hier
zurück laufen lassen derzeit dann haben
wir nie eine eindeutigkeit ursache sind
immer die ambivalenz weil es ja immer
noch ein zustand da vorgeht wenn sie das
bis ins unendliche denken können sie
daraus eine schließen
es gibt eben nie wirklich ursache sind
von jedem das können sie mathematisch
mit induktion und beweisen können sie
immer optisch im minus eins machen dann
haben sie eben nie das bald seine
ursache fest machen können sie immer
sagen da gibt es aber wieder eine
ursache davor und das unendliche gedacht
daraus können sie dann schließt es gibt
eigentlich gar keine richtige ursache
das ist so so der gedanke
und ich glaube das hat war es durchaus
[Musik]
es ist einfach das problem nach links
gedacht oder wir sehen uns die anderen
teilnehmer denn hier also ganz da gibt
es natürlich viele probleme und da
können sich gerne in der nach hause bei
damit auseinandersetzen ja wie ist diese
vollständigkeit überhaupt verstehen uns
geht es um andere meinung dazu
musik quasi dann sich selbst schließen
und das dann die ursachen die mich ihr
kommen rein des steines die da vom 12
gerade wenn du dich zu motivieren werden
mögliche gründe
[Musik]
genau also ich denke auch dass das
problem hier ist dass das sagt kann auch
selbst also kann wird dann sagen die
antinori die wir jetzt konstruiert haben
die können wir auflösen sagt also wir
haben in der 52
die anti nomi angelegt wir haben in der
vernunft zwei gegenseitig sich
ausschließende thesen aber unsere fans
gibt uns zugleich noch das mittel in die
hand diesen widerstreit aufzulösen
naja also die vernunft ist der grund des
widerstands und auch der grund der
auflösung dieses wieder streit
das ist ganz spannend und das behandelt
kann alles in der transzendentalen
dialektik dass es mir jetzt auch noch
ein wichtiger begriff den ich hier an
die tafel schreibt muss dialektik
dialektik ist verkannt die logik des
scheins dialektik meint der ursprünglich
wie sie alle wissen in der
mittelalterlichen scholastik das trivium
ja es gab als ein trivium und ein
quattro jung 1 1 3 weg auch der heutige
ist heute gehört trivial hängt damit
zusammen dass waren also diese sieben
freien künste september ots liberal ist
die waren die bedingungen dafür dass man
überhaupt ein großes fach wie medizin
und jura zum beispiel studieren durfte
dazu musste man da vorerst
diese sieben freien künste gelernt haben
oder gibt es eben rhetorik grammatik
dialektik das sind solche grund künstler
solche probe tätigen könnte man sagen
solche hinführung auf diese große
studien fächern wie jura und medizin und
auch natürlich theologie
die drei sind die großen fakultäten
rechtswissenschaften
medizin und theologie bevor man die
studieren durfte musste man diese sieben
freien künste erlernt haben und eine
dieser freien künste war eben die
dialektik und die elektrik meint
eigentlich nur die argumentation des
kunst die logik die mittelalterlichen
scholastik logik kunst also irgendwie
sie kennen vielleicht dieses viereck
dieses quadrat oder gibt es hier
verschiedene positionen kann man sagen
das wirklich so und so das ist dieser
modus dass es dieser modus
mittelalterliche logik die im
wesentlichen auf der aristotelischen
lüge aufbauen
das ist die dialektik und die dialektik
hat in der neueren zeit keinen guten ruf
gehabt bekannten sagte der diagnose
scholastic das ist bloß so vernunft
spielereihe tasche spielerei der
vernunft gutem 1 wagen deswegen hat
gerade gesagt das ist eigentlich nur die
logik des scheins hier kommt unsere
vernunft mit sich in verwirrung das ist
eine vernünftig spielen und elektrik
hals also logik des scheins dialektik
heißt unsere vernunft selbst hat die
tendenz einen schein zu erzeugen unsere
vernunft selbst täuscht sich selbst das
erstmal sehr paradox kann sagt aber und
das gute daran ist die vernunft die sich
selbst täuscht hat aber auch die mittel
zur verfügung sich selbst aus ihrem
scheins befreien und das nennt kann dann
die kritische philosophie politische
philosophie heißt sie müssen eben
gewisse unterscheidungen einführen die
die natürliche vernunft nicht tut und
die unterscheidung ist zb intel giebler
charakter und phänomenaler charakter
also die welt hat zwei aspekte einer
empirischen aspekt und ein intel
liebling aspekt und jetzt sind wir diese
unterscheidungen vornehmen dann können
wir die vernunft aus ihren bekannt auch
sagt automatischer schlummer oder aus
dieser dialektik freien wie wild auf den
begriff der dialektik nicht weiter
eingehen weil wir sie alle wissen der
begriff vor allem bei hegel noch eine
ganz neue bedeutung hat regel nimmt dann
diese diesen gedanken bei kant auf dass
die vernunft in sich ein widerspruch
erzeugt und zugleich auflösen kann
hegel wendet dann diese dialektische
strukturen nicht allein auf die vernunft
an also auf ein vermögen nach kannte
ein subjektives vermögen von hegel
bildet diese struktur auf die ganze welt
als solche nicht nur auf die wilson auf
die ganze entwicklung des universums
also nach hegel diese nicht irgendwie
nur die vernunft dialektisch sondern
unsere begriffe sind dialektisch also
die grundstrukturen des grund größte der
welt ist so verfasst wie nach kannten
unsere fünfte hat zb sein und werden
oder sein und nichts da haben wir das
sein dass nichts die stehen sicher anti
tisch gegenüber und wir können sie
wiederum aufheben dialektisch durch das
werden und so gerät die ganze ganze
erkenntnis der welt in bewegung und aus
den verschiedenen widersprüchen der
begriffe die wir haben können wir dann
durch solche synthesen die ganze welt
letztendlich erklären
das ist also nur soviel zum thema
dialektik ein ganz schillernder begriff
ähnlich schillernd wie der begriff der
willkür dass es gar nicht so klar was
damit gemeint ist also in diesem rahmen
der dialektik verwendet behandelt kann
jetzt diese antinori wie gesagt in der
hausarbeit können sie sehr gerne diese
frage behandeln inwiefern diese kette
vollständig oder unverständnis haben so
wie wir es jetzt gemacht haben gründe
anführen das spricht dafür was spricht
dagegen
also jetzt sagt er hier der ein beweis
der vernunft sagt also wir brauchen hier
noch eine andere form von kausalität
etwas freiheit eine mentalität die
überhaupt das in gang setzen der
kausalkette ermöglicht und jetzt sagt
kann aber wir haben auch eine gegenthese
eine anti tecis dies ist keine freiheit
sind alles in der welt geschieht
lediglich nach gesetzen der natur wie
nennt man diese position nach der
wie haben sie eine idee wie könnte man
die nennen das die position eines
deterministischen genau während die
vorherige position wie würden sie denn
die jetzt nochmal klassifizieren und sie
sagen ja
ja das geht so ein bisschen die richtung
aber das problem ist ja hier an diesem
punkt mit der spontaneität
da geht ja der determinismus ja nicht an
diesem punkt also der determinismus wird
ja so ein bisschen im grants gesetzt
wenn sie mal genau hinschauen weil wir
haben ja durch den determinismus nie so
eine erste unfall erst anfangen
also die freiheit fundiert in der termin
ismus oder das naturgesetz ja unsere
freiheit entscheidungen macht es
überhaupt möglich dass natur
gesetzlichkeit als solche erscheinen
kann ja ok ist das jetzt ein kompatibles
muss
eigentlich müsste man doch sagen also
nach dem kompatibel es muss müsste sich
das naturgesetz bis uns endlich zurück
laufen immer weiter und zugleich müssten
wir frei sein
es dürfte also nicht so einen absoluten
anfang geben spontaneität
deswegen gibt es eigentlich gründe dafür
dass er ein liberta realismus zu finden
weil der determinismus eingeschränkt
wird wir beweisen hierbei eine these die
wahrheit der freiheit durch eine
einschränkung des determinismus nicht
jetzt in seiner ganzen ketten struktur
aber in dem ersten anfang dass wir den
determinismus fundieren durch das
freiheits gesetz also da gibt's jetzt so
ein argument für den libertarian ist uns
dieser dieser geschichte da aber es auch
kein richtiger liberta realismus warum
denn nicht
auf welche position muss ich den der
libertarian ismus denkt sie an robert
kam nochmal beziehen
um baufreiheit ermöglichen zu können es
musste ja noch vom determinismus sagen
er muss sagen diese tennis ist falsch
aber nicht nur nicht irgendwie falsch
hier im ersten anfangen das ist erkannt
soll was sagt er
die beta realismus eigentlich über den
determinismus
sie sagt
es gibt ja
das wäre der mysterien ismus genau das
wäre jetzt peter von ihnen wegen der ist
ja auch so ein bisschen liebert aria
liebert ariane aber ich glaube es ist so
man müsste sagen der libertarian ist
liberianer die sagte determinismus ist
falsch und zwar deswegen weil wir eben
ein in determinismus noch haben wir
haben in der termin ist ische zustände
und die ermöglichen dass du dir das muss
so aufzuweichen
dass dazwischen die freiheit platz hat
das ist so die tendenz ist auch kein
typisch klassische liberta realistischer
ansatz einfach deswegen weil das der
determinismus ganz konsequent gedacht
wird nachdem er einmal in gang gesetzt
als solche fragen können sich gerne vor
setzen wenn sie eine hausarbeit bekannt
schreibt wollen ja jetzt ganz viele
möglichkeiten zu prüfen
jetzt kommt die antithese und zwar es
ist keine freiheit sind alles in der
welt geschieht mit literatur das ist
natürlich ein klassischer determinismus
ein harter determinismus es gebe eine
freie im trans and arlen verstanden
also das ist die trans endteile freiheit
diese erste absolute ursache die alles
gegangen sitzt ist die trans dentale
freiheit bekannt jetzt in dieser diesen
texten setzt es gebe eine freiheit die
trans and arlen verstand als eine
besondere art von kausalität nach
welcher die gegebenheiten der welt
erfolgen könnten nämlich ein vermögen
einen zustand mit dem auch eine reihe
von folgen derselben schlechthin
anzufangen
das ist diese absolute anfangen
zur wird nicht allein eine reihe durch
diese spontanität soll die bestimmung
dieser spontanität selbst zu
hervorbringen der rai das ist die
kausalität wird schlechthin anfangen so
dass nichts vorher geht wodurch diese
geschehen der hand und nach beständigen
gesetzen bestimmt sein
es setzt aber ein jeder anfang zu
handeln einen zustand der noch nicht
handelnden ursache voraus und ein
dynamisch erster anfang der handlung
einen zustand der mit einem
vorhergehenden eben derselben ursache
gar keinen zusammenhang der kausalität
hat das heißt auf keine weise darauf es
folgt also ist die trans zentrale
freiheit dem haus hall gesetz entgegen
und eine solche verbindung der
sukzessiven zustände wirken der ursachen
nach welcher keine einheit der
erfahrungen möglich ist die also auch in
keiner erfahrung angetroffen wird mithin
ein leeres gedanke dass es jetzt das
problem nach dieser auffassung
warum sagt kann können wir uns jetzt
auch nicht ihr so eine dürfen jetzt
nicht so eine totale freiheit wie sie er
ist hier nennt als absoluten anfang
denken
was sagt er
entscheidend ist hier der letzte punkt
hier dieses also als es müssen bei
kannten immer so ein bisschen darauf
achten wo signalwörter kommen und also
ist zwar ein wort bekannt einen schluss
bringt das ist die konklusion also das
ist die folgerung alte sie dann dass
alle freiheit ist widersprüchlich weil
keine einheit der erfahrung dadurch
möglich würde
was heißt das dass keine erfahrung
dadurch möglich würde
wir müssen sie sich denn jetzt so eine
transzendentale freiheit im alltag
vorstellen
im 1
das heißt es
wir sind keine feinde
zb ein wunder das wäre ein wunder wenn
jetzt etwas passieren würde was nicht
durch vorhergehende natur ursachen
erklärt werden könnte da tritt ist ein
eigenes auf was die bedingungen der
möglichkeit von natur gesetzlichkeit ist
aber selbst nicht mehr naturgesetzlich
beschreibbar ist weil es ja der grund
dieser naturgesetz beschreibt barkeit er
ist ist das das meint kann auch mit
transzendentalen also die bedingung der
möglichkeit von und die bedingung der
möglichkeit unterlegt natürlich nicht in
ihren eigenen bedingungen oder den
bedingungen des jähnigen was es bedingt
ich kann diesen absoluten anfang nicht
im rahmen dieser kausalität stehen die
er erst begründet das heißt wie sie ganz
wichtig sagen die einheit unserer
erfahrung würde zerstört werden weil
hier ganz glücklich so sachen geschehen
würden die wir nicht mehr
naturgesetzlich verstehen könnten die
auch gar keine nur froh keine
ursächlichkeit hätten dass irgendwas
plötzlich passieren so aus dem rahmen
fallen
das kann man sich dann wiederum nach
kant in einer sie kennen alle die
unterscheidung in der mathematik wenn
sie also einen grafen haben eine kurve
haben können sie zum beispiel sagen wenn
sie die eine welt linie haben so xy
achse können sie sagen einem bestimmten
punkt zeitpunkt haben sie keine
differenzierte funktionen oder keine
stetige forschung wie auch immer so
könnte das also versuchen zu erklären
sie haben denn hier so einfach ein
grafen hier sei jetzt mal so hier ist
ypsilanti ist xx zeit mein weg auch die
zeit t
und sie haben hier so eine welt linie
und jetzt haben sie aber plötzlich hier
einen punkt in der welt linie
und jetzt
so wachsen
haben sie hier ein problem an diesem
punkt
als es dann nicht sie kennt die
differenz ihr barkeit und stetigkeit da
man könnte es auch so machen dass man
hier ein knick hat so haben ja auch ein
problem
das wäre dann so ein bisschen was mit
seiner absoluten spontanität die einheit
der erfahrung die stetigkeit die natur
gesetzliche tätigkeit beschreibt barkeit
unsere welt linie wird hier an einem
bestimmten punkt unterbrochen
also dasjenige was eigentlich die
einheit der erfahrung leisten sollte die
einheit der kausalität hier ist jetzt
auf einer anderen sichtweise gerade
nicht mehr in der lage die einheit zu zu
erzeugen sondern sie gefährdet filme die
einheit der erfahrung weil wir keine
stetigkeit mehr haben oder differenziert
wie auch immer das ist also hier das
argument leute dass ihnen ein welche
diese leute ihnen jetzt mehr ein
die erste these oder die gegenthese oder
würden sie sagen beide gleich wenig oder
beide gleich sehr wie ist der meinung
dass die erste these überzeugen niemand
wird meint dass die zweite these
überzeugen ist der meinung dass beide
gleich wenig oder gleichviel überzeugend
sind ja also bekannt geht auch so ein
bisschen in diese richtung wie sie jetzt
mehrheitlich sich entschieden haben als
er sagt erster ist ein bisschen ja er
wird deutlich dass am ende sagen beide
sind letztendlich gleich falsch dann
müssen sie auflösen
aber ja also nach der heutigen sicht ist
auf jeden fall ganz klar die zweite
these einleuchtende also die antithese
kann wird jetzt sagen sind beide falsch
und wir müssen sie beide auflösen
nach dieser dialektik mal an der these
antithese und dann sind es das ist diese
dialektik
im ansatz richtig
nachdem nach der dialekte der fünfte ist
beides wichtig aber nach der kritischen
philosophie eben nicht weil eine
wichtige unterscheidung beiden thesen
noch fehlt nämlich die unterscheidung
zwischen ding ansicht und erscheinung
und diese unterscheidung wird hier beide
male nicht gemacht das ist jetzt wir
kommen jetzt gleich zur auflösung also
das ist die antenne muss aufgelöst
werden und zwar durch eine wichtige
unterscheidung die beide thesen nicht
genügend berücksichtigt dass die trans
zentrale unterscheidung zwischen ding an
sich oder intelligent geben karte und
phänomenalen charakter das ist alle die
schlüssel unterscheiden was das jetzt
genau auf sich hat müssen wir jetzt noch
hier klären also jetzt wollen wir mal
hier gleich auf die arm an die auflösung
gegeben einen punkt gibt es jetzt noch
hier zur antithese er sagt wir haben
also nicht als natur in welcher wieder
in zusammenhang und ordnung der welt
begeben halten suchen müssen die
freiheit unabhängig von den gesetzen der
natur ist zwar eine befreiung von zwei
aber auch vom leitfaden aller regeln
das ist ihr punkt mit der willkür dass
der positive wirkung denn man kann nicht
sagen dass anstatt der gesetz natur der
freiheit gesetze der freiheit in die
kasse des welt laufs eintreten weil wenn
diese nach gesetzen stimmt wäre sie
nicht freiheit sondern selbst nichts
anderes als natur wären nur als ultra
zentrale freiheit unterscheiden sich die
gesetzmäßigkeit und gesetzlosigkeit
davon jene zwar den verstand der
schwierigkeit belästigt die abstimmung
der begebenheiten in 3d ursachen immer
höher hinauf zu suchen also höher hinauf
meint jetzt hier nicht nach rechts zu
verlaufen sondern nach links also
praktisch zurück das meint er mit höher
wir decken mit hör eigentlich immer
derzeit weiter dachte aber wir würden
sagen tiefer er meinte damit die
höher stehenden gründe die zeitlich
vorhergehenden ursachen weil die
kausalität an ihnen jederzeit bedingt
ist aber zur schadlos haltung
durchgängige und gesetzmäßige einheit
der erfahrung von spricht dahingegen das
blendwerk der von freiheit zwar den
forschenden verstanden in der kette der
ursachen sowohl verheißt indem es ihn zu
einer unbedingten kausalität für die von
selbst zu handeln an lebt die arbeit da
sie selbst blind ist den leitfaden der
regel ab preis an welchem allein eine
durchgängige zusammenhängende erfahrung
möglich ist
ich habe schwierigkeiten mit der
positiven
das also da unklar
ja also mir scheint dass er hier das als
etwas kontradiktorisch es versteht
nämlich dass wir
durch die freiheits kausalität eben
keine gesetze hätten also es geht jetzt
hier darum um gesetzlosigkeit wer es
gesetzlich kann
das war der hinweis dass kommilitonen
also sie haben auch zu recht hingewiesen
dass innerhalb dieses ganzen kontextes
man es so verstehen könnte das wehr
setzt hier eine erste anfassten anfang
gibt dass der einfach willkürlich ist so
einfach so bloß artig was ich habe dann
schon ein bisschen voraus griffen und
gesagt nach unserem unterscheidung von
vernunft gesetz und freiheits gesetz ist
eigentlich das freiheits gesetz von ulf
gesetz und als wenn du mich gesetzt eben
nicht willkürlich das hat zumindest ein
grund einer rationalen grund aber auf
dieser lesart kann zeigt er hier noch
überhaupt nichts von vernunft kommt noch
überhaupt nichts rein insofern haben sie
völlig recht
dann könnte man es so lesen dass hier
einfach plötzlich uns stattfindet wie zb
in dieser kurve hier einfach plötzlich
so ein knick stadt führen wird einfach
der natur gang kommt eine neue richtung
verliehen und die richtung kann sich
nicht kann nicht erklären aus den
vorhergehenden das heißt man muss diesen
richtungswechsel hier bei diesem knick
dieser kurve
diesen richtungswechsel dem muss man
auch etwas anderes erklärt aber man kann
nicht mehr aus der natur heraus erklären
und wenn man einfach nur sagt ist ein
absoluter anfang dann ist damit über die
bestimmtheit gesagt nein man kann ja
wieder fragen aber warum waren jetzt
hier
das ist jetzt der grund von diesem
anfang und die antwort darauf müsste
sein nichts wenn es dafür einen grund
gäbe müsste es davon wieder einen grund
geben und dann hätten wir dasselbe
problem mit in der natur kassel tätig
als die einzige antwort nachdem jetzt im
bild die wir haben leere nichts es ist
einfach so und damit schluss und das ist
natürlich unbefriedigend für unsere
vernunft wir wollen immer gründe haben
selbst etwas was absolut spontan
sicherheit und der schlüssel zu dieser
problematik den haben wir schon ein
bisschen verwicklung der wird eben sein
das kann sackt der grund für diesen
absoluten anfang der ist eben hier in
der vernunft zu liegen und zum einsatz
und die die normativität das sollen dass
die ist eben gerade so dass es sich
unmittelbar aufdrängt und zwar nicht im
gefüge der natur ursachen die eine also
die die vernunft und das moral gesetzt
die konstituierende eigentlich eigene
realität die unabhängig ist von dem
zeitlauf der naturgesetze aber
nichtsdestoweniger bestimmt ist
also wir haben es hier eben gerade nicht
wie wir noch sehen werden also in
absoluten ursachen mit willkür zu tun
schlechten sinne soll mit höchster
bestimmtheit aber eben mit normativer
bestimmt hat und nicht nur mit des
captain bestimmt
das ist als die unterscheidung wir
können etwas sehr wohl bestimmt denken
und nicht als in der zeit stehen auf
fassen wenn wir es normativ zb deuten
denken sie zum beispiel an wert
vergegenwärtigen sich das mal anhand des
eines wertes oder eines handlungs
wenn sie nach werten handeln
dann könnten sagen der grund dass ich so
und so handelte war der wert die
überzeugung meine maxime ist und dann
würden sie sagen dieser wert der wird
nicht zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
eingesetzt und aktiv sind der wert um
fast mein ganzes leben also die
normativität darf nicht so verstanden
werden wie ein grund der in der zeit
liegt sondern werte von tieren unser
ganzes leben ja werte ermöglichen uns
verschiedene handlungen aber nicht in
dem sinne dass sie ein erster anfang
sind was plötzlich auftaucht sind es
liegt allem was wir tun nur zu gründen
das heißt werte und normative
überzeugungen haben eine andere logik
nämlich sie sind eigentlich nicht so
sehr zeitlich verfasste punktuell sie
haben ausgedient hat und das ist ein
erster fingerzeig dafür dass wir diese
absolute ursächlichkeit nicht so
verstehen dürfen als ob sie mit der
natur gesetzlichkeit auf derselben ebene
konkurrieren würde insofern sie auch in
der zeit stattfinden diese annahme liegt
die überzeugung zugrunde
dieses problem liegt die annahme
zugrunde dass freiheits qualität und
natur kausalität beide in der zeit
stattfinden
dann haben wir natürlich ein problem
dann plötzlich in der zeit um das t ist
hier auf der x-achse beantragt haben
einen bestimmten zeitpunkt plötzlich was
ganz anderes alte müssen um die santino
me aufzulösen eine andere zeitliche
logik zugrunde legen der auffassung von
absoluter ursächlichkeit
es darf nicht mehr im sinne einer
zeitlichen kausalität verstanden sondern
es muss normativ stadt werden und das
wollen wir das mal genauer anschauen
jetzt kommt er also normal gibt es eine
nebenbemerkung zur these also die these
smart diese quasi liberalen liberta
realismus oder quasi kompatibles muss
wie auch immer man es nennen so ich
glaube ja das kann weder libertarian und
noch kompatibel ist ist irgendwas
drittes was den genannten gründen die
sie sehr gut in einer hausarbeit man
sich vornehmen können ganz spannendes
thema alte zutiefst sagt die trans
zentrale idee der freiheit macht zwar
bei weitem nicht den ganzen inhalt des
psychologischen begriffs dieses namens
aus welcher großenteils empirisch ist
sondern nur den der absoluten
spontanität der handlung als den
eigentlichen grund der input agilität
also der zu recht barkeit selben ist
aber dennoch die eigentliche stein des
anstoßes für die philosophie welche über
wirkliche schwierigkeiten findet der
gleichen art von unbedingter kausalität
einzuräumen
dasjenige also in der frage über die
freiheit des willens jetzt kommt
plötzlich die freiheit des millionsten
spiel was die spekulative vernunft von
jeher in so große verlegenheit gesetzt
hat ist eigentlich nur trans sind teil
und geht lediglich darauf ob ein
vermögen angenommen werden müsse eine
reihe von sukzessiven
aufeinanderfolgenden dingen oder
zuständen von selbst anzufangen
wie ein solches vermögen möglich sei ist
nicht ebenso notwendig beantworten zu
können da wir uns eben sowohl bei der
kausalität nach naturgesetzen damit
begnügen müssen a priori zu erkennen
dass eine solche vorausgesetzt werden
muss ob wir gleich die möglichkeit wie
durch ein gewisses dasein das dasein
eines anderen gesetzt werde auf keine
weise begreifen und uns des falls
lieblich an erfahrung halten müssen
jetzt kommen hier plötzlich neue
begriffe ins spiel nämlich
die psychologie und mit der psychologie
kommt eben auch der begriff der im
portabilität als der moralischen
zurechenbarkeit ins spiel
und hier kommt noch die freiheit des
willens also der wille kommt auch noch
ins spiel und es kommt doch was ins
spiel nämlich der begriff eines
vermögens was auch im rahmen einer
psychologie zu behandelt werden kann
also es geht jetzt um unseren freien
willen
wie können wir den jetzt hier verstehen
wir müssen einen freien willen annehmen
um moralisch zurechenbaren zu sein wenn
wir eben nur dem naturgesetz unterliegen
sind wir für nichts mehr zur
verantwortung zu ziehen ist doch ganz
klar dass das problem dass determinismus
ja ok weiter geht es nun haben wir diese
notwendigkeit eines ersten anfangen es
eine reihe von erscheinung aus freiheit
zwar nur eigentlich insofern da getan
als zur begreiflichkeit eines ursprungs
der welt erforderlich ist indessen dass
man alle nachfolgenden zustände für eine
abfolge nach losen naturgesetzen
annehmen kann
weil aber dadurch doch einmal das
vermögen eine reihe in der zeit ganz von
selbst anzufangen bewiesen ob zwar nicht
eingesehen ist so ist es uns wo man auch
erlaubt mitten im lauf der welt
verschiedene reihen der kausalität nach
von selbst anfangen zu lassen und den
substanzen derselben ein vermögen
beizulegen aus freiheit zu handeln
man lasse sich aber hierbei nicht durch
einen missverstand aufhalten das dann
nämlich eine sukzessive in der welt nur
einen komparativ ersten anfang haben
kann indem doch immer ein zustand der
dinge in der welt vorher geht etwa kein
absolut erste anfang der reihe während
der welt laufe möglich sei denn wir
reden hier nicht von absolut ersten
anfang der zeit nach solln der
kausalitäten
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel völlig
freien ohne notwendig bestimmenden
einfluss der natur sachen von meinem
stuhl aufstehen so fängt in dieser
begebenheit samt deren natürlichen
folgen uns unendlich eine neue frei
schlechthin an obgleich der zeit nach
diese begebenheit nur die fortsetzung
einer vorhergehenden rey ist diese
entschließung und tat liegt gar nicht in
der abfolge klose natur wirkung ist
nicht eine bloße fortsetzung des heben
sollen die bestimmende natur sachen
hören oberhalb dessen anziehung dieses
ereignisses ganz auf das zwar auf den
erfolg aber daraus nicht erfolgt und
daher zwar nicht der zeitnahe aber doch
in ansehung der kausalität ein
schlechthin erster anfang einer reihe
von erscheinungen genannter werden muss
louis
das ist jetzt aber ganz schön
kompliziert also kann möchte jetzt hier
dieses diese antithese auflösen
also welche modifikationen nimmt kann
jetzt vor an der ts
ich sage das will man in unseren
umsätzen
irgendwas
nein
nämlich so etwas aus dem rahmen
wieder andere werden
ein schild mit der ersten hat
genau nehmen sie jetzt mal dieses
beispiel noch dazu mit dem stuhl kann
bringt nur an sehr wenigen stellen ein
beispiel
und das bringt uns jetzt hier weiter
also wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel völlig
frei und ohne den notwendig
ja wenn ich jetzt also völlig frei und
ohne den notwendigen stimmen den
einfluss der natur sachen von meinem
stuhl aufstehen so fängt in dieser
begebenheit samt deren natürlichen
folgen nun endlich eine neue reihe
schlechthin an gleich ändere etwa im
vergleich dazu wenn ich den sitzen
verändere den lauf der entwicklung
das könnte sich mit dem
schmetterlingseffekt baustellen selbst
ein noch so kleines ereignis das ich was
sich ändert kann auf lange frist hin
extrem große veränderungen wirken also
schmetterling effekt meint dass also ein
flügelschlag eines schmetterlings einen
wirbelsturm auslösen kann ja jedenfalls
klein noch so kleine ursachen könnten
der kontext von anderen ursachen extreme
veränderung bewirken
also fängt das hat er natürlich einen
folgen und endlich eine neue reihe
schlechten an das ist klar obgleich der
zeit nach diese begebenheit nur die
fortsetzung einer vorhergehenden rey ist
denn diese entschließen der tat liegt
gar nicht in der abfolge bloß einer tour
wirkung und ist nicht bloß eine
fortsetzung des erbes sein die bestimmte
natur sagen hören oberhalb derselben in
anziehung dieses ereignisses ganz auf
das zwar auf viel erfolg
aber daraus nicht erfolgt und daher zwar
nicht der zeit nach aber doch den
anziehung der causa tätig schlecht den
ersten anfang an der reifen erscheinen
dann wären muss jetzt bringt er eine
wichtige unterscheidung in diesen
letzten zahlen haben sind die gesehen
unterscheidet zwischen zwei weißen
[Musik]
genau also hier haben wir das war auf
jene folgt dass es die zeitliche folge
aber daraus nicht erfolgt das ist die
kausale folge
wir müssen als unterscheiden von
zeitliche abfolge und logischer oder
kommunaler abfall und kann würde sagen
das ist jetzt dieser kompatibel ist muss
der jetzt ein bisschen differenzierter
betrachtet wird also wir wenn wir
aufstehen dann können wir dieses
freiheits ereignis in der zeit sehr wohl
nach naturgesetzen bestimmen habe eben
nicht der logik nach der kausalität nach
als aus naturgesetzen erfolgt das ist
also jetzt dieser versuch des
kompatibles muss kann versuchte zeigen
dass ein freies ereignis wie zum
beispiel es aufstehen auf einem stuhl
vollständig derzeit nach durch
naturgesetz erklärt werden kann
aber der kausalität nach nicht durch
naturgesetze also der geltung nach
sozusagen der genese des stehen nach
kann man das sehr gut durch naturgesetz
erklären aber die geltung nach nach der
frage nach dem grund der dafür zum
gefühlt hat geben nicht dass also dieses
erfolge und bloß folgen und jetzt müssen
wir schauen wie kant das versucht also
hier sehen sie versucht jetzt kann
dieses problem zu lösen
mit diesem ersten anfang an sagt also
kette läuft hier bis ins unendliche
weite aber dennoch können wir uns dazu
die freiheit denken
die bestätigung von dem bedürfnis der
vernunft in der rai der natur ursachen
sich auf einen ersten anfang aus
freiheit zu berufen leuchtet daran sehr
klar in die augen
dass die ep chorische schule ausgenommen
alle philosophen des altertums sich
gezwungen sahen zur erklärung der welt
bewegungen ein ersten bewegen anzunehmen
das ist eine frei handeln die ursache
welche diese reihe von zuständen zuerst
und von selbst anfing
denn aus bloßer natur unter vielen sie
sich nicht einen ersten anfang
begreiflich zu machen
als er mit den ersten wählern das kennen
sie auch bei aristoteles so was man die
causa sui grund zeit selbst ein unbewegt
vega als dies durch und als epicor
imitierten die dachten eben dass die
natur selbst nicht in der lage sein
könnte einen ersten anfang begreiflich
zu machen und da sagt jetzt kann das ist
ein bedürfnis der vernunft das ist die
dialektik wir wollen hier ein erster
anfang habe und jetzt kommt es zur
antithese da macht jetzt kann auch
einige wichtige unterscheidungen geld
sagt der verteidiger der alpha mögen
heidi natur trans zentrale physio grad
im wieder spiel mit der lehre von der
freiheit würde seinen satz entgegen der
vernunft hätte die vernünftigen schlüsse
der letzteren auf folgende art behaupten
wenn ihr kein mathematisch erstes
derzeit nach in der welt annehmen so
habt ihr auch nicht nötig ein dynamisch
erstes der kausalität nachzusuchen
wer hat euch geheißen ein schlechthin
ersten zustand der welt und mithin einen
absoluten anfang der nach und nach ab
laufenden 3 die erscheinung zu erdenken
und damit ihr eure einbildung einen
ruhepunkt verschaffen möge der
unumschränkten natur grenzen sie sitzen
da die substanzen in der welt jeder zeit
gewesen sind so wenigstens die einheit
die erfahrung eine solche zu hause zum
notwendig macht so hat es keine
schwierigkeit auch anzunehmen dass der
wechsel tiere zu stellen das ist eine
reihe ihrer veränderungen jederzeit
gewesen sei und mithin kein erst anfang
weder mathematisch noch dynamisch
gesucht werden dürfe
die möglichkeit eines solchen
unendlichen abstammung ohne ein erstes
glied in dessen alles übrige bloß
nachfolgend ist lässt sich seiner
möglichkeit nach nicht begreiflich
machen wenn ihr diese natur rätsel darum
wegwerfen wollte so werdet ihr euch
genötigt sehen viele synthetische grund
beschaffenheiten
grund kräfte die er ebenso wenig
begreifen könnt und selbst die
möglichkeit einer veränderung überhaupt
muss euch anstößig werden denn wenn ihr
nicht durch erfahrung findet dass sie
wirklich ist so würdet ihr niemals
apriori es sind können wie eine solche
unaufhörliche folge von sein und
nichtsein möglich sein
die zehn neuen punkt der noch wichtig
ist
jetzt geht es also um die antithese um
die these dass alles nur durch das
naturgesetz bestimmt ist
hier gibt es zwar ein unterscheidung
zwischen den mathematisch ersten und dem
dynamisch ersten ich verstehen sie denn
diese unterscheidung
das war die schwerste zeit
ich denke auch dass in diese richtung
gibt gelesen man nochmal das next zitat
wenn auch in dessen allenfalls ein trans
sind alis vermögen der freiheiten
nachgegeben wird um die welt
veränderungen anzufangen so würde dieses
vermögen doch wenigstens nur außerhalb
der welt sein müssen wie wohl es immer
eine kühne anmaßung bleibt außerhalb dem
inbegriff für alle möglichen anschauung
noch einen gegenstand anzunehmen der in
keiner möglichen wahrnehmen gegeben
werden kann
allein in der welt selbst den substanzen
ein solches vermögen beizumessen kann
immer mehr erlaubt sein weil als dann
der zusammenhang nach einem allgemeinen
gesetze sich einander notwendig
bestimmte erscheinung den man natur
nennt mit ihm das merkmal empirischer
wahrheit welches erfahrung vom traum
unterscheidet größtenteils verschwinden
würden
denn es lässt sich neben einem solchen
gesetzlosen vermögen der freiheit kaum
natur denken weil die gesetze der letzte
hand dadurch durch die einflüsse der
ersteren urlaub würdig abgeändert und
das spiel der erscheinung welches nach
der bloßen natur regelmäßig und
gleichförmig sein würde dadurch verwirrt
und und zusammen gemacht hängt gemacht
wird dass es wieder dieses problem was
sie genannt hatten mit dieser einheit
der erfahrung mit den wundern
das wäre als ein bloßes spiel der
erscheinung sondern jetzt einmal in der
einem der vorigen sind hatte schon so
ein schlüssel bekommen zur auflösung
dieser anti nomi nämlich eben dieses
folgen und erfolgen hat das ist also ein
wichtiger schlüssel und die zeitlich
logik und jetzt kommen wir noch am
schluss in den letzten sechs minuten
sieben minuten auf die auflösung der
kosmologischen ideen wie man das jetzt
also hier auflösen kann diese antinori
wir haben eigentlich den schlüssel zum
zur auflösung ist schon gesehen der
schlüssel wird der sein dass wir eben
die absolute spontaneität die causa sind
aus freiheit nicht in die zeit setzt
dürfen sondern sie vor aller zeit
sie müssen so wie unsere werte auch
nicht in der zeit existieren als
ereignisse sondern unsere werte die
geben den horizont ab innerhalb dessen
wir handeln
das sind motive die aber nicht in der
zeit liegen sondern die einfach vor der
zeiten darüber derzeit liegen wie auch
immer und diesem sinne denkt jetzt kann
diese auflösung kosmologische ideen sind
einfach ideen die das erste und letzte
betreffen kosmologische geht es eben um
den allerersten anfang
das hat mit der freiheit zu tun deswegen
nennt qantas die kosmologische den man
kann sich nun zweierlei kausalität in
anziehung dessen was geschieht denken
entweder nach der natur oder aus
freiheit die erste die haus der natur
ist die verknüpfung eines zustandes mit
einem vorigen in der innenwelt worauf
jeder nach einer regel folgt dann die
kausalität erscheinungen auf zeit
bedingungen gut und der vorige zustand
wenn er jederzeit gewesen wäre auch
keine wirkung die allerersten der zeit
entspringt hervorgebracht hätte so ist
die kausalität der ursache dessen was
geschieht oder entsteht auch in stand
nun bedarf nach den verstandes grundsatz
selbst wiederum eine ursache dass das
problem dieses immer weiter
zurückreichen ist ins unendliche zurück
dass die vollständigkeit er nicht
gegeben ist dagegen verstehe ich unter
freiheit in kosmologischen vorschnell
das vermögen einen zustand von selbst
anzufangen
deren qualität also nicht nach dem
naturgesetze wiederum unter einer
anderen ursache steht welches sie nach
der zeit bestimmt die falten dieser
bedeutung ist eine reine trans zentrale
idee die er sich nichts an der erfahrung
entlehnt es enthält zwei deren
gegenstand auch in keiner erfahrung
bestimmt gegeben werden kann weil es ein
allgemeines gesetz selbst der
möglichkeit alle erfahrung ist dass
alles was geschieht eine ursache mithin
auch die kausalität der ursache die
selbst geschehen oder entstanden
wiederum eine ursache haben müssen
wodurch denn das ganze feld der
erfahrung so weit ist sich erstrecken
war in einem inbegriff loser natur
verwandelt wird dabei auf solche weise
keine absolute totalität bedingung im
kausalen verhältnis herausgekommen ist
so schafft sich die vernunft gd von
einer spontaneität die von selbst
anheben können zu handeln ohne dass eine
andere ursache an geschickt werden
dürfen
sie wiederum nach dem gesetz die kausale
verknüpfung zur handlung zu bestimmen
also jetzt sind diese trends sind alle
freiheit ihr sie davor genannt hat nennt
er jetzt sie auch kosmologischen freien
fall in kosmologischen stande einen
zustands von selbst anzufangen
deren kausalitäten nicht die naturgesetz
unterlegt ist aber merkwürdig auch dass
auf diese transit idee der freiheit sich
der praktische begriff der sieben gründe
und jene in dieser das eigentlich im
moment der schwierigkeiten ausmachen
welche die frage über ihre möglichkeit
von jeher umgeben haben die freiheit im
praktischen verstande ist die
unabhängigkeit der willkür von den
nötigungen durch antriebe der
sinnlichkeit denn eine willkür ist
sinnlich sofern sie pathologisch durch
bewegung sachen der sinnlichkeit afi
ziert ist sie heißt tierisch atrium
proton wenn sie pathologischen existiert
werden kann
die menschliche willkür ist zwar ein
atriums sensitiven aber nicht proton
sondern die lieferung weil sinnlichkeit
ihre handlungen nicht notwendig macht
sind dem menschen ein vermögen beiwohnen
sich unabhängig von der nötigung durch
ziemliche antriebe von selbst zu
bestimmen also etwas sagte jetzt hier
sagt jetzt hier das mit dieser trend
ahlen geht der freiheit als der frage
nach dem allerersten anfang von der welt
überhaupt also trans en thale freiheit
macht hier überhaupt welt möglich in
ihrem werden stehen durch den ersten
anfang nichts erkannt auf diesen
kosmologischen eigentlich mit
menschlicher freiheit als solche gar
nichts zusammenhängendes begriff darauf
gründet sich die praktische freie die
praktische freiheit ist eine freiheit
die auch was mit moralität zu tun hat
die was mit unserer zurechenbarkeit zu
tun also auf diese sehr abstrakte
freiheit des ersten anfangs in der welt
jüngsten urknall mit dieser idee es
erkannt hängt unsere praktische freiheit
zusammen die auch unseren willen
bestimmt und der wille ist so verstimmt
genau die willkür die wiki ist bestimmt
durch zwei verschiedenen einflüsse arten
sie kann bestimmt werden durch die
sinnlichkeit des
alles was dem naturgesetz unterlegt oder
sie kann bestimmt werden durch die
vernunft
heute dass vernunft gesetz es gibt auch
ein vermögen ist erkannt im menschen
dass sich der wille bestimmt unabhängig
von der nötigung durch sinnliche antrieb
also jetzt wird das ganze diese ganze
freiheits debatte also diese
unterscheidung von naturgesetzen
vernunft gesetzt auf den menschlichen
willen eingezogen
der wille und der wille kann bestimmt
werden durch das tor gesetzt und durch
das vernunft gesetzt indem wir jetzt den
willen einführen als dieses vermögen was
sich bestimmen kann nach dem ein oder
anderen haben wir schon einen ersten
schritt auch zur auflösung getan weil
der wille natürlich beide zusammen
bringt der wille ist auch so ein
schlüssel neben dieser unterscheidung
von großer zeitlicher folge und logisch
oder kausale folge ist der wille eine
solche instanz die uns ein mittel gibt
diese land antinori aufzuheben
jetzt lese ich noch das letzte zitat vor
und wir machen der nächsten sitzung noch
ein bisschen weiter
man sieht leicht dass wenn alle
kausalität in der st innenwelt los natur
wäre so würde jede begebenheit durch
eine andere in der zeit nach notwendigen
gesetze bestimmt seien und mit hinter
die erscheinungen sofern sie die willkür
bestimmen jede handlung als ihren
natürlichen erfolg notwendig machen
müsste so würde die aufhebung der trans
zentralen freiheit zugleich alle
praktische freiheit vertreten
wenn diese die praktische frei setzt
voraus dass gleich etwas nicht geschehen
ist es doch habe geschehen sollen
und seine ursache in der erscheinung
also nicht so bestimmend war das nicht
unser weg für eine kausalität liege
unabhängig von jedem natur sachen und
selbst wieder ihre gewalt und einfluss
etwas hervorzubringen was in der zeit
ordnung nach empirischen reserven
bestimmt ist mithin eine reihe von
begebenheiten ganz von selbst anzufangen
hier nur ein kleiner hinweis kommt jetzt
zum ersten mal das solle
ja also das tolle ist jetzt ein einfluss
unserer vernunft in der natur die
vernunft qualität zeigt sich durch das
sollen letztes zitat jetzt es geschieht
also hier was überhaupt in die
widerstreit einer sich über die grenzen
mögliche erfahrung hinauswagen
angetroffen wird dass die aufgabe
eigentlich eigentlich nicht
physiologisch sondern transzendentale
seien daher die frage von der
möglichkeit der freiheit die psychologie
zwar ansicht aber da sie auf die
elektrische argumenten rosenrot samt
ihrer auflösung lediglich die trans en
tal philosophie beschäftigen muss und
nun diese welche eine befriedigende
antwort hierüber nicht ablehnen kann
dazu entstanden zu setzen wo sich
zuvörderst ihr verfahren bei dieser
aufgabe durch eine bemerkung herr zu
bestimmen zu können
und jetzt kommt eben der entscheidende
schritt und den werden wir im nächsten
und letzten sitzung mit diesem semester
noch genau folgen
jetzt kommt kann es unterscheidung
zwischen erscheinungen und dingen an
sich selbst oder erst setzt wenn
erscheinungen dinge an sich selbst wären
mit den raum und zeit formen des daseins
der dinge an sich selbst so würden die
bedingungen mit den bedingten jederzeit
als gegner zu einer unter selben reihe
gehören und daraus auch im gegenwärtigen
fall die an die anthologien springen die
allen trans and arlen ideen gemeint ist
dass diese reihe unvermeidlich von
verstand zu groß oder zu klein ausfallen
müsste kurz gesagt und das ist nur eine
antizipation der nächsten sitzung kann
unterscheidet jetzt zwischen den blues
in theley bln bereich des intelligenten
das ist dann das ganze hier auf dieser
seite vernunft gesetzt
das gesetz moral gesiegt und den blues
empirisch und das ist alles dasjenige
was dem naturgesetz unterlegt und durch
diese unterscheidung zwischen dem
empirischen und im internen charakter
den wir selbst auch an uns tragen will
kann versuchen zu zeigen dass wir
freiheit und determination das samt
denken können und diese auflösung dieser
dritten anti nomi gehen wir dann dem
nächsten sitzung noch etwas weiter nach
sie finden die folien die aktualisierten
folien alle auch auf die lowcost und ich
schicke ihnen die noch warum und wenn er
noch ein bisschen zeit bleibt der
nächsten sitzung werden wir uns noch
ganz kurz mit zart riss finance theorie
beschäftigen der ja auch immer an kant
wirken wie also kann es position ist so
bedeutend dass alle modernen denke dass
19 und 20 jahrhunderts selbst ist 21ten
jahrhunderts in dem wir leben nicht
eigentlich sinnvoll über feiert reden
kann ohne sich darauf zu beziehen dann
bis zur nächsten sitzung